♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
HERE IS A QUESTION NOBODY ASKS,
WHY ARE DEMOCRATS SO ANGRY?
JUST DAYS FROM NOW THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS LIKELY TO
RETAKE THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, AND WITH IT,
MEANINGFUL POLITICAL POWER.
NEARLY EVERY POLL PREDICTS THAT
WILL HAPPEN.
WE WILL SEE.
BUT DEMOCRATS OUGHT TO BE
CHEERFUL AND CONFIDENT.
INSTEAD THEY LOOK LIKE THIS.
>> YOU ARE SUPPORTING NAZIS.
>> DON'T POUR YOUR COFFEE ON ME.
>> I WILL.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND THAT FASCISM
IS HERE?
I HOPE YOU ALL REALIZE THAT YOU
ARE NORMALIZING AND ENABLING
NAZIS.
YOU CAN FILL ME, I DON'T GIVE A
[BLEEP].
DO YOU REALLY CARE?
DO YOU?
[BLEEP] [BLEEP]
>> Tucker: THE VIDEO YOU JUST
SAW WAS FLORIDA, BUT IT COULD'VE
BEEN BEEN ANYWHERE ELSE
DEMOCRATS OCCUPY.
FING NAZIS, THAT IS THE
DEMOCRATIC SLOGAN.
THE REAL ENEMY IS AMERICA'S
MIDDLE CLASS, WHICH THEY
CONSIDER DISGUSTING AND IMMORAL.
WATCH THE NEXT POINT.
>> YOU HAVE RACISM AND SEXISM
DRIVING THIS VOTING BASE AND WE
HAVE TO CALL THAT OUT AND
ADDRESS THAT.
>> AMERICA GREAT AGAIN, MAKE
AMERICA WHITE AGAIN.
>> I THINK THIS IS A BIG RACIST
PART OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> HE DOES HAVE TO TAKE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE TYPE OF
RACIST CLIMATE WE FIND OURSELVES
HIM, WHICH IS NOT NEW.
DO YOU HEAR ME SAY THIS ALL THE
TIME, THIS IS THE DNA OF AMERICA
TIME, THIS IS THE DNA OF AMERIC.
>> Tucker: IT'S THE DNA OF
AMERICA.
THE COUNTRY THAT VANQUISHED THE
NAZIS IS ITSELF A NAZI COUNTRY.
IS THIS GOING TO HELP GET OUT
THE VOTE ON TUESDAY?
IT SEEMS HARD TO BELIEVE THAT
WOULD BE AN EFFECTIVE CAMPAIGN
TACTIC.
THEY ARE SAYING IT BECAUSE THEY
REALLY MEAN IT.
THE LEFT IS SO ANGRY THEY CANNOT
EVEN REASON.
THINK BACK A COUPLE YEARS AGO OF
ALL THE PUBLIC FIGURES HE WANTS
THOUGHT OF AS IMPRESSIVE.
YOU MIGHT HAVE NOT AGREED WITH
THEIR POLITICS, BUT THERE WAS NO
QUESTION THERE WERE SERIOUS
PEOPLE.
JAMES CLAPPER, BILL KRISTOL.
WHERE ARE THOSE PEOPLE TODAY?
WE ARE FOAMING AND RANTING ON
TWITTER LIKE DRUNK CHILDREN.
HOW ABOUT JOHN BRENNAN?
NOT SO LONG AGO, HE RAN THE CIA.
THAT'S A SERIOUS JOB.
HERE'S WHAT JOHN BRENNAN SOUNDS
LIKE NOW.
>> HE IS FEEDING AND FUELING
HATRED AND ANIMOSITY AND
MISUNDERSTANDINGS AMONG
AMERICANS.
>> I USE THE TERM THAT THIS IS
NOTHING SHORT OF TREASONOUS
BECAUSE IT IS UP A TRAIL OF THE
NATION.
HE IS GIVING AID AND COMFORT TO
THE ENEMY.
TREASONOUS IS DEFINED AS A
BETRAYAL OF TRUST AS WELL AS
AIDING AND ABETTING THE ENEMY.
THAT'S THE WORD THAT CAME TO MY
MIND.
>> Tucker: TREASON.
AIDING AND ABETTING THE ENEMY.
PEOPLE DIDN'T USED TO SAY THINGS
LIKE THAT IN PUBLIC, NOT FOR A
LONG TIME.
NOW IT'S JUST ANOTHER MIDDAY
PANEL ON MSNBC.
MEANWHILE, THE REST OF US ARE
FAR LESS AFRAID TO SAY WHAT WE
THINK THEN WE WERE JUST A FEW
YEARS AGO.
OUR CULTURE GROWS LESS OPEN AND
MORE STIFLED.
WE MUST ABANDON POLITICALLY
UNPOPULAR RESEARCH.
ORDINARY PEOPLE FEAR THAT THEY
SNATCH FROM THE SENSITIVITY
DEPARTMENT DOWN THE HALL WILL
CATCH US IN THE SMALLEST
VIOLATION OF THE LIBERAL
CATECHISM AND WE WILL BE FIRED
AND HUMILIATED.
THE LEFT IS CLAMPING DOWN WITH
MAXIMUM FORCE ON DISSENT.
THEY DEMAND NOTHING LESS THAN
TOTAL OBEDIENCE TO THEIR
EVER-EXPANDING PROGRAMS, WHOSE
OUTLINE CHANGES AND ARE
CONFUSING PEER TO STEP OUT OF
LINE, THOUGH, AND THEY WILL HURT
LINE, THOUGH, AND THEY WILL HURY
LINE, THOUGH, AND THEY WILL HURU
LINE, THOUGH, AND THEY WILL HUR.
WHY IS THE LEFT DOING THIS?
BECAUSE THEY ARE LOSING AND THEY
KNOW IT.
TAKE A STEP BACK FOR A MINUTE.
HIS HUMORLESS POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS THE HALLMARK OF
SELF-CONFIDENCE?
NO, IT'S JUST THE OPPOSITE.
ARMIES DON'T BEHAVE LIKE THIS,
CRUMBLING REGIMES DO.
THIS IS HOW YOU ACT WHEN YOU
FILL YOUR POWER SLIPPING AWAY.
DEMOCRATS WILL LIKELY WE MAKE
THE ELECTION ON TUESDAY, THEY
MAY WOULD MAKE THE NEXT
ELECTION, TOO.
ULTIMATELY, DOESN'T REALLY
MATTER BECAUSE THEIR PROGRAM IS
OVER.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
VOTERS ARE REJECTING THEIR
IDEAS, AND THEY ARE DOING IT
AROUND THE WORLD.
IN COUNTRY AFTER COUNTRY,
GLOBALISM AND CULTURAL
LIBERALISM ARE DYING.
IF YOU WATCH CNN, YOU MIGHT
CONCLUDE THAT AMERICA IS SOMEHOW
AN INTERNATIONAL PARIAH FOR
HAVING A PRESIDENT WHO CALLS
HIMSELF A NATIONALIST.
BUT IF ANYTHING, TRUMP IS JUST
ONE AMONG MANY.
HOW MANY MAJOR DEMOCRACIES STILL
HAVE GOVERNMENT EVEN CLOSE TO AS
LIBERAL AS THE AMERICAN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
ALMOST NONE OF THEM.
IT'S ALL MOVING IN THE OPPOSITE
DIRECTION, AND IT'S MOVING AT
HIGH SPEED.
VOTERS EVERYWHERE WANT THEIR
LEADERS TO CARE ABOUT AND
PROTECT THEM.
THE GLOBALIST LEFT CAN NEVER
DELIVER ON THAT BECAUSE THEY
CANNOT ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
CONCERNS OF ONE COUNTRY MIGHT
OUTWEIGH THOSE OF ANY OTHER
COUNTRY.
IT WOULD BE AS IF THERE PARENTS
LOVED THE NEIGHBORS KIDS AS MUCH
AS THEY LOVE TO YOU, MAYBE MORE.
YOU WOULD HATE THAT.
VOTERS HATE THAT.
THAT'S WHY AS LONG AS DEMOCRACY
IS ALLOWED, THE GLOBALIST LEFT
IS DOOMED.
PROGRESSIVES KNOW THAT.
IF THEY CAN SMELL IT, AND IT
TERRIFIES THEM, SO THEY CRACKED
DOWN ON THE POPULATION.
YET, THAT WILL NOT WORK.
YOU CAN'T BULLY AND HARANGUING
YOUR OWN PEOPLE FOREVER.
THERE IS A LIMIT, AND WE ARE
REACHING THAT LIMIT.
KEEP THIS IN MIND AS YOU WATCH
THE ELECTION RETURNS ON TUESDAY